what did you think about the backlash
too uh
uh
i don't it's just it's it's like you can
almost just write it up you can just
write up what's gonna happen who's gonna
say what yeah who's gonna it's cause for
concern but it's never
it's just that's like the theater of it
the the uh
you just know what's everything is
pretty like predictable outcome yeah
there's
mark just finished it like we did a
podcast last week and then mark just
finished it and then you brought up a
really good point mark and i'll let you
articulate it but about like uh
that they're disagreeing on different
things the two communities
oh yeah yeah it seemed like i i likened
it to like the abortion debate that like
you have one side that's like you hate
women the other side's like you're
killing kids it's like they're not
arguing on the same
like what it even means to disagree so
like so when it comes to the trans issue
it's like one side is saying by by by
saying that gender is a biological fact
right you are making me invisible as a
trans person that you're saying i don't
exist
and it minimizes me and my community and
that's what i consider transphobic i
guess is right inside of the trans
argument and then the other side is
i guess like oh i love you and i'm
accepting you and i don't want you to be
discriminated against and i don't want
any legislation against you as a trans
person but also i think you're kind of
crazy
and that's right it feels like the other
side is that like i'm not gonna hurt you
i don't i'm not trans phobic i don't
hate you i'm not afraid of you but also
like you know come on let's be honest
like it's a guy and it's a girl and
you're just like playing dress up or
something so there's like dysphoria you
have some mental disorders yeah so like
the trans community is basically saying
yo if you don't think trans is real
that's transphobic right and then
everybody else and i'm putting that in
quotes but like the majority of people
are just like i'm not transphobic i
don't want them to die right i don't
want them to get beat up but do i think
that it's it's real or i think they're
making it up well this is also one of
those things of like now we're getting
it's
abortion's a great analogy for it which
is you know what i realized a while ago
about abortion i don't [ __ ] know
i it is
expensive
not
quite
i'll talk to you after the show
i got a guy i got pills i got a lot of
stuff
um
concoction
but they
you i don't [ __ ] know i don't know
what you are now a woman and you are not
a one you're i don't [ __ ] know i
don't know what an idea
no no but what i'm saying is like like
abortion where it's like people go
i know when it's a life and when it
isn't
how the [ __ ] do you know yeah i don't
[ __ ] know i don't know i i'm not
saying i get the i used to do a j i
never did it as a joke but i used to do
a joke on the phone with gerard which is
abortion is kind of killing kind of a
baby
like you're not fully a baby
yeah yeah um and that's with trans stuff
i'm like i don't know
like when you officially
are a man or a woman or i like in terms
of like or turf or
like is a is a operated on woman
the same as a what is a
what's a woman do you know what i mean
like what is that [ __ ]
i don't know those are maybe chicks that
have
vagina female anatomy but internal
testes that making testosterone what is
that yeah that is a very complicated
porn search is what that is
some people got like three chroma or
three uh well you're talking about the
girls that were left out of the olympics
yeah yeah the namibian chicks yeah it's
not even their fault yeah yeah they're
just really
good at running yeah yeah and they love
mma
no but it is it is interesting like if
that
if both sides are arguing different
things of course they're not going to
understand each other so if you believe
that just not believing in trans people
is transphobic right of course the jokes
are going to seem like that to that
community right if you're out here like
you know i got trans friends like
everything's good i don't hate you why
you call me transphobic is because
you're not going off of their definition
right and that's why nobody's gonna
understand it well that's also like
it benefits both sides to not be
understood
it benefits
like there's a victim victimization is
like currency
so
you know yeah i'm
it's it's what uh you ever hear kurt
metzger has a term it's so [ __ ] like
a uh cultural flop
you know when like in the nba like the
flop where people are just flopping like
wow did you see that
and and like the nba stopped
that up that that steph curry thing
that's no longer going to be a foul we
need to bring that
into the world where it's like no it's
not a foul no contact yeah or there is
contact but you initiated contact and if
you if you fake and then lean in it's
not a [ __ ] foul
so now there's people that that uh are
those people like the people who are
offensive to be offensive just well
they're it's like there's that and then
there's also people that are offended to
get the sympathy
energy
yeah they are the they fly it's a lot of
people flop it's like a soccer thing
where one guy flops and another guy
flops and then and then there's a
stretcher i like when they bring the
stretcher
but yeah i don't i it's just not it's
predictable yeah it's just entirely
predictable baked into the marketing
i'm not saying this what dave did but
like you've seen like certain ad
campaigns use racism as marketing like
they put out a kind of racist ad and
then of course the internet goes crazy
everybody's talking about head and
shoulders everybody's talking about
whatever detergent remember i think it
was like an asian commercial where they
put the black guy in the laundry machine
right and i love it and then he comes
out white he comes out white i love
what's the name of the detergent
what is the name of it
um bleach no don't say it
i almost did it no but it is um
i just i just feel like it's it's part
of like the outrage marketing now like
if you're putting out a project
and it's not pissing off you have to
find what could be like trying to get a
book canceled so it becomes a
better yeah but you got to be really
specific with the community because you
piss off the wrong community they'll
take away your book right there are
certain communities where big
corporations will turn a blind eye and
it kind of looks like trans the big
corporate like if you go at like gay
well no there's pretty it's another kurt
massacre there's like protected groups
but so and then some are more protected
than others yes
like and it takes a while
like uh
certain people are not like like short
people fat people
you can still like it's like that yeah
yeah fat people i don't even think you
have to yeah it's like that's choice
right like nobody else's choice right
but this is the this is it's all all of
these things have like come on
stop put the hamburger like or it's
glandular or it's whatever like or they
ca or they got they don't get good uh
yeah people have uh have thyroid things
and whatever uh also people get thyroid
didn't have anything
and she's never been fatter
just literally
that's where all the food goes i guess
yeah it stops right there with the
thyroid yeah that was the issue with the
thyroid
but yeah there's all and then there's
people that like well they're poor they
didn't get uh uh nutrition
explain to them correctly they're in
food deserts there's like reasons for it
it's kind of all the same thing right
but there's all kinds you need to
explain nutrition bro
you need to tell people if they eat ice
cream [ __ ] on yeah yeah right of course
but all of these things start as come
the [ __ ] on yeah and then you guys like
i yeah it's like i'll never call someone
they and then they show up i'm like
hello bae like i haven't done that
uh i don't know any days i'll do it if
they ask but it is grammatically hard
don't you think
yeah i said they'll they ask yeah there
you go like it is tricky right it's like
somebody had a really good would they
like somebody somebody had a really good
argument against they which is i'm not
going to call them they because they're
singular
they're only one person but they feel
like they're more i i know again that's
the thing it's like i don't it's just
but i just respect the rules of english
like all right that's it it's just
really simple yeah
it that all but if you don't know if you
don't know the gender then you would use
that
but not to their face right you would
say what would you like and then yeah
but then you wouldn't you wouldn't use a
third person pronoun anyway um
yeah i don't even see a real practical
application the thing that all these
things have in common they are very
boring yeah
they're very boring so they don't help
me either
yeah they don't they just inconvenience
yeah they don't benefit me in any way
how can you make it easier for me and
then i'll do it
yeah i just it's like it's all the stuff
that like it start none of it's very
i don't mind doing it i guess i the
thing i do mind is when
if i forget or i make an honest mistake
it's bad faith interpretation that
wasn't an honest mistake that was an
aggressive
mistake that is violence
and it's like i just [ __ ] up i
couldn't america couldn't learn metric
yeah
do you think we're going to learn all
these [ __ ] new
gender and i would assume most days
are pretty cool with you [ __ ] up
because they're used to people [ __ ]
up yeah yeah yeah but i think there are
a small number of people who want the
attention and want the victim currency
who make it a big deal and i think the
rest of they are like already
mistaken that's tricky dude of course
yeah you're going to make a mistake but
if we're friends for four months you'll
probably figure it out yeah but the
first time you talk to me yeah it's
going to be vigilante's on twitter that
get pissed and [ __ ] like the guy who was
in the store like the the gamestop dude
yeah who i think he's done a couple
things like he's clearly out here
flopping for clouds yeah yeah and what
is it called i love this term flopping
but like culture flopping i think
culture flopping for clout is pretty
great yeah he's flopping cloud flapping
out
yeah so so
beyond that i just like all right i
don't it's not just like cool yeah and
then people were like do you someone was
like you need to condemn this one no i
don't i don't [ __ ] agree with
anything every there's nothing you have
a platform anyone on earth who i agree
with 100 yeah so my mom not like
there's nobody so why do i need to uh
specifically well everything he says i i
mean that
we share a bank account yeah yeah me and
dave yeah it's great also what are you
gonna say i'm disappointed
yeah what am i gonna what am i what's
that annie what good is anything gonna
do i just no it's you're not living and
you're not a lot of a lot of it seems
like a lot of people just aren't living
in reality
you